Speaker 1: Things are really heating up for people
around Donald Trump. We saw some bombshells in the
January six hearings, but additionally, his former
advisor and someone who spread the big lie a lot,
Peter Navarro, was recently arrested and is having
to beg MAGA for money to fight his legal battles.
What a fallen star. Reading from Business Insider,
former Trump adviser Peter Navarro said he was put
in handcuffs and leg irons while being
arrested after trying to board a flight
at the airport in Nashville on Friday. Navarro
was indicted on charges of contempt of Congress
on Friday after repeatedly defying
the orders of the House committee
investigating the January six riot per unsealed
court documents. So he didn't comply with a
January six committee subpoena, and because of
that, he got arrested. And after that arrest,
the desperate complaining immediately began with
him calling the FBI agents who arrested him Nazis
and saying he was treated like he was he was in
al Qaeda. Of course, the Justice Department is
disputing his characterization of those events.
But now, as greater men such as Rudy Giuliani
have had to do after being left in Donald
Trump's dust, he's out asking for money from MAGA
to fight his legal battles. Let's take a look.
Speaker 6: Yes, yes. I mean, this is so wrong.
Seven This book Taking Back Trump's America.
Help me, please. I'm looking at a half a million
dollars in legal expenses, according to some
legal experts or more. This could go to a million.
I've got to raise that money. I. I can't kill my
retirement by. By defending this baseless charges.
Taking back Trump's America. Please go to Amazon
right now. All right. Book, book. The book.
Speaker 1: The aches, happy, are not you, Peter?
I will say in all seriousness, we should not
take pleasure in this just because we don't like
someone watching them crash and burn. That's just
not cool. No, I'm kidding. That was awesome. So in
a world that's so tough, it's nice to see people
who tried to assault our democracy and spread lies
about a free and fair election. Get a little bit
of punishment. Okay, that's pretty nice. Like
I said, he refused to comply with a January six
committee subpoena. And it's a good sign that the
Justice Department is finally getting a little bit
more justifiably aggressive in their enforcement.
And hopefully we'll see that trend continue.
Of course, only with crimes that have actually
been committed, not for political reasons,
but if you can uncover real crimes, the
Justice Department, even if it's touchy,
people need to actually take appropriate
actions. I'll be following this story closely,
seeing what happens with Peter Navarro on my
channel. You can check it out. Luke Beasley on
YouTube. That's obviously why if you're watching
on YouTube or listening to the podcast, there will
be a link in the description. You can click to
check out my channel. I encourage you to do so.